it's that time again to talk to you bout
the latest games in new releases and
this week you get to meet the scholar of
the first sin or relive Dark Souls 2 as
if it was the first time on current-gen
systems but it's not just a pretty new
face you get new pretty environments new
pretty enemies and lore enemy placements
will alter the way you played previously
changing it up to make you more
defensive or more aggressive the weapons
are also switched around so for people
who felt like they played the entire
game with the great sword you're more
likely to have a different character
much sooner graphically it looks super
hot so it's got that going for it go
into the dark area on the 7th also this
week you want to go into space but you
don't want to spend a lot of money
affordable space adventures is here to
put you in your fancy spaceship with
your fancy friends the engineer gets to
check temperature gauges fuel thrust and
anti-gravity meters to ensure you don't
incinerate your friends but if kerbals
taught us anything it's that if you want
to make an omelet you gotta crack few
holes to space you go on the night but
what's this randomly generated
first-person shooter with an art style
that screams Borderlands it's tower of
guns seven floors of crazy enemies boss
battles loot and guns in a frantic
bullet hell style game that's completely
randomized modify your shotgun to
ricochet or stack your double jumps to
never touch the ground again and it can
be yours for fifteen dollars or the
better price of free if you're a
PlayStation Plus subscriber and you can
get it starting on the 7th also this
week well-known game with a massive
universe robust story and a psychic
sword somehow gets compressed into the
new 3ds fluid game to be late Xenoblade
Chronicles is a sublime wonderfully
paced game that both refines and
modernizes the Japanese role-playing
game and it's making its way to the new
3ds to show off how impressive that
little device truly is if anything this
really opens the door for future
exclusives to really pack a punch in the
graphics department but for now we get
this imaginative in a
native and compelling RPG you could pick
it up on the 10th but for those of us
still carting around the regular 3ds
consider the etrian oddysey mystery
dungeon Masha Etrian mystery dungeon you
still get character classes and skill
trees but now with dungeon exploration
and a new fixed perspective where you
can control a party of up to four
characters it comes to north america on
the 7th finally one of the most
beautiful games to ever appear on the pc
gets its gorgeous debut on ps4 this week
so prepare your arsenal and get prepared
to drink some of the finest spirits to
ever grace the bastion who doesn't want
a nice ice cold drink of leachate and if
anyone else knows where to buy bastion
brandy in real life you let me know you
can face the calamity on the 7th for
further details visit gamespot com
release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change see
you next week strong cuz clean the
lengthy 42